des conditions de pêche qui ne font pas
l'unanimité des français parce qu ils
les estiment contraires à l'accord
commercial post break site
une cinquantaine de pêcheurs français a
décidé de manifester pacifiquement ce
jeudi matin à l'entrée du port de
saint-hélier capitale de l'île anglo
normande de jersey des dizaines de
bateaux naviguent venus des côtes
normandes et bretonnes
ils protestent contre les nouvelles
restrictions en vigueur prises
unilatéralement selon le gouvernement
français
ooyala aujourd'hui comme wall a toujours
poussé dans les halls à la douleur pcc
et paix du cool du jour au lendemain
on en rêve tous les droits de péage
ouvert
cd accordé depuis
des protestations pacifiques qui n'était
pas vouée à bloquer les navigations
mais le capitaine du port de jersey a
refusé de laisser sortir des bateaux
tant que les pêcheurs français et
stationneraient sur les eaux anglo
normandes
après le déploiement de deux navires de
guerre anglais de patrouilleur français
les autorités des deux pays ont annoncé
s'être retiré des eaux anglo normandes
boris johnson avait affirmé son soutien
indéfectible à jersey alors que le
secrétaire d'état français aux affaires
européennes avait déjà réagi à la
situation tendue
ces manoeuvres ne doivent pas nous
impressionner je me suis entretenu avec
david frost le ministre britannique
chargé des relations avec l'union
européenne
notre volonté n'est pas d'entretenir des
tensions mais d'avoir une application
rapide et complète de l'accord rien que
l'accord est tous d'accord
la france travaille en lien étroit avec
la commission européenne qui souhaite
également un apaisement des tensions
que faisons-nous à ce sujet nous sommes
en train de nous engager de bonne foi
avec le royaume uni pour essayer de
résoudre cette situation c'est le point
où nous en sommes actuellement et je ne
pense pas qu'il serait bon pour moi ou
pour nous de dire quoi que ce soit sujet
de vive tension entre londres et paris
les îles anglo-normandes dispose d'un
cadre législatif et d'une fiscalité
spécifique qui ne facilite pas les
relations entre les deux pays
ce mardi à la suite des nouvelles
restrictions prises par les autorités
britanniques
la france s'est dit prête à recourir
avec regret à des mesures de rétorsion
si cela est nécessaire
aujourd'hui si les pêcheurs viennent
d'annoncer leur retrait des eaux de
jersey la situation semble toujours
aussi difficile à démêler